3월 달에 거래가 총 여덟 권이
됐는데 일곱
건이네 투자라고 하는 이유가 바로
이런
[음악]
겁니다 제가 빌딩 거래량이 좀
늘어났다고 했는데 기사를 통해서
얼마나 늘어나는지 한번 좀 보여
드리도록 하겠습니다 1분기 상업용 뭐
빌딩 거래 여섯 분기만에 최고 치로
거래가 됐다 작년보다는 좀 더
올라갔습니다 전체적으로 보면은
어찌됐든 작년이 제일 안 좋았어요
거와 비교에서는 조금 상승한 것으로
보여지는데 근데 지금 22년도
21년도 이때 피크 대와 비교해서는
아직까지 좀 많이 적죠 거래량이 일단
작년보다 괜찮아졌는데 회복된 상태는
좀 아닌 것으로 좀 보여지고요
1분기에 그리고 거래 금액이 제일
높았던 빌딩은 아크플레이스 거의
8천억 원에 매각이 됐었고 22년
이후에 거래된 거 중에는 규모가 큰
거라고 합니다요 데이터에서 10억
미만 빌딩인 65% 차지한다고 합니다
우리가 보통 투자하는 금액이 뭐
10억 에서 100억 미만의 빌딩들이
좀 많이 있는데 요거를 좀 중점적으로
보셔야 됩니다 요거 두 번째 기사
보면은 4월 28일 날 나왔던
기사인데 강남만 살아남았다 뭐 이런
식으로 기사가 좀 나갔습니다 강남구
1분기 거래량이 61건 그까 정년
동기 대비해 49% 정도 상승했다고
합니다 그래서 작년 1분기가 제일 안
좋았는데 와 비해서 49% 정도
상승을 했고 거래 규모 거래 금액도
한 두배 정도 늘어났다고 합니다
서울시 전체적으로 한 300 63권
정도 거래가 됐는데 강남구 거래량이
좀 되게 높았다고 하고요 이제
금액대는 50억에서 100억 대부분은
다 대지면적이 한 100평 미만 정도
되는 꼬마 빌딩 규모가 좀 거래가
많이 됐어 그래서 요즘에 좀 팔리는
거 보면은 좀 이렇게 강남이나 팔리는
곳만 좀 팔립니다 또 이런 댓글이
많아요 그래서 너는 왜 맨날 강남만
얘기하고 뭐 성수나 한남 막 이런데만
왜 얘기하냐 좀 외곽 지역에 임대수익
잘 나오는 빌딩이 더 괜찮은 거 아니
냐 근데 제가 계속 얘기 드리는게
어찌됐든 잘 팔리는 곳에 사야 돼요
이게 빌딩이 제일 중요한게 환금성이
제일 문제인데 나중에 안 팔리거든요
근데 여러분들이 안 팔리는 지역에
잘못 샀다가 나중에 팔리지도 않고
원가보다 손해 보고 파는 경우도 되게
많거든요 그래서 오늘이 기사를 좀
유심히 보실 필요가 있는 것 같습니다
이제 오피스 필딩 큰 이제 프라임급
빌딩이 3월 달에 거래가 총 여덟
권이 됐는데 일곱 권이 강남 권이라고
합니다 영등포나 중국 마포 이런 데는
거래가 한 건도 없었습니다 이렇게
금액이 더 클수록 이쪽에 사실 몰려
있어요 그래서 좀 정리를 해
보겠습니다 어 작년보다는 거래량이
늘긴 했습니다 20년도 19년도가
비교했을 때 아직 완벽하게 회복하지
않았습니다 거래량이 상승하긴 했지만
주로 거래된 거는 서울시에 좀 거래가
많이 됐고 그리 서울 중에서 강남권
거래량이 좀 많이 상승했습니다 강남권
같은 경우에는 작년 1분기와 대비해서
거의 거래량이 한 49% 정도 어
상승을 했고요 그리고 주로 거래되는
금액대는 50억에서 100억 정도
되는 코마빌딩 규모의 빌딩들이 거래가
좀 많이 살아났습니다 그리고 이제
프라임급 빌딩 그니까 이제 되게 큰
빌딩들도 강남곡 미주로 좀 거래량이
많이 상승했다고 좀 보시면 될 거
같습니다 제가 계속 말씀드리는 그런
좀 잘 팔리는 지역의
빌딩들에 투자라고 하는 이유가 바로
이런 겁니다 지금 상황이 좋지 않지만
좀 이런 주요 지역에 있는 들은 계속
거래가 되기 때문에 여러분들이 이런
기사들을 좀 참고해서 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
어 제가 이런 기사들이나 이런 좀
업데이트 되는 거 있으면 좀
정기적으로 촬영하도록 하겠습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]